よろしくお願いします
では 熟語場面 イダ・ソーチャティ・ペッチャ・ソーチャティ・パープカーリ・ウバヤッタ・ソーチャティ・ソー・ソーチャティ・ソー・ヴィハンニャティ・ディッスワァ・カッマ・キリッチャ・マッテノと
いう偈です
こういうのは偈というんですけど
普通 「詩」という意味なんですね
すごい今日はすごい簡単な偈で
ではもう一度見てください
イダ・ソーチャティ・ペッチャ・ソーチャティ・パープカーリ・ウバヤッタ・ソーチャティ・ソー・ソーチャティ・ソー・ヴィハンニャティ・ディッスワァ・カッマ・キリッチャ・マッテノ
意味なんですけど イダっていうのは「今ここで」という意味なんですね
いわゆる「この世の中で」っていう意味ですね
ソーチャティ 「悩む」
ペッチャっていうのは「これから」というね
イダという言葉は「今」ということになってくると
ペッチャは「それから」
いわゆる一般的に言えば
イダは「この世で」なると
ペッチャは「あの世」ということになるんですね
ペッチャ・ソーチャティ 「
あの世でも悩む」と 「
今も悩んでこれからも悩む」という意味なんですね
パープカーリ・ウバヤッタ・ソーチャティ
パープカーリ パープカーリっていうのは
パープっていうのは「悪」のことで
カーリっていうのは「する人」ということは「悪人」という意味なんですね
罪を犯す人 悪人 で パープカーリ・ウバヤッタ
ウバヤッタっていうのは「両方」という意味で 「
どちらでも」 ソーチャティ 「
悩む」 「両方どちらでも」っていうのは 「
この世とあの世」っていうことで 「
こちらもあちらでも悩んでしまいますよ」と
次はまた強調するんですね
ソー・ソーチャティ 「
彼が悩む」 ソー・ヴィハンニャティ
ヴィハンニャティっていうのはもうもう破滅になるというかね
すごくこの 悩んで悩んでどうしようもないことになることなんですね
一応ヴィハンニャティっていうのは
辞書の意味っていうのは「破滅になること」なんですね
何かもう一つ言葉あるでしょうと思いますけど
っていう  先生  うん  ここでいう破滅っていうのは具体的にどういうことですか
破滅だけではちょっとよくわからない
え？ 破滅っていう言葉だけではよくわからないんですけど
人間が破滅するっていうのは具体的にはどういうことですか
だからソーチャティは「悩むこと」だからね
悩むことしかない人はどうなるんですかね
暗く言ったらそのまま暗いままいるだけ
それだけ  はい  それで人生は成功する？ いえ
破滅っていうと 何か具体的にこれが終わりっていうか
破滅 最終的なものがあるような気がするんですけど
だいたいそういうことになるんでしょ
だから悩んで悩んで悩むことしかない
こちら行ってもあちら行っても悩むと
楽しみのことは 1つもないと
悩み方がどんどん増えるでしょ
そこで自己破壊になってしまうということでね
で まあこれから説明しますからね
[笑い]次に あのディスワーカンマキリッテーマッテノー
ディスワーというのは見てということで
カンマキリッタン キリッタンという言葉が先に来ます
キリッタンというのは汚れた
汚れた カンマン 行為 汚れた行為をディスワー見てという意味なんです
だからまあ 後ろから前に持ってこないと日本語にならないんですね
今度はもっと後ろに行かなくちゃいけない
アッテノー 自分の そうすると自分の汚れた行為を見てということになるんです
それでこういう偈 日本訳するとどうなるかというと
日本語にすると この一番
四番目の一番最後のものは一番前に持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあもう一度 この最後の行ディスワーカンマキリッテーマッテノー
それを先に持っていって
アッテノー 自分のキリッタンカンマンという汚れた行為をディスワー見て
自分の汚れた行為を見て
それも先に行くんです
イダソージャティ ここでも悩む
ペッチャソージャティ
後からもこれからも悩む
そのように悪人はどちらでも悩んでいるんだよ
それで彼が悩む 悩み 悩み果ててもう破滅になると
破滅っていうのはちょっと強烈かもしれませんけども
もうほとんど何かもう違う言葉あった方がいいなと思いますけどね
こちらは憂いという言葉使っていますから
日本訳でね 憂いと悩むということはね
まあやっぱり悩みの方が憂いよりはいいかもしれませんですけど
まあヴィハンニャティといえば
この悩むと憂いのちょっとすごい強い状態なんですね
もういわゆるもうどうにもならない状態
悩み果てて 悩み果てて
このどうにもならない状態はヴィハンニャティという言葉なんですね
このヴィハンニャティっていうのは
この辞書でこのハンという言葉から作る動詞なんですね
ハンというのはもう殺すという意味なんです
ヴィ入ってくると この
まあただまあ殺されるみたいな意味になっちゃうし
破壊するっていうことになるんですね
だからヴィハンニャティっていうのは
この あの あれ あの 何と言いますか
オブジェクトというかね
あの 対格がない動詞ですね
あの 英語だったらtransitive verb, intransitive verbと二つありますね
これintransitive verbなんですね
例えば私が何々をするといった場合はtransitive verbで
私が遊ぶと言ったらintransitiveなんですね
対格は要りません だからヴィハンニャティっていうのはintransitive verbで
我々日本語で何言うかわからないんです
あ 自動詞 他動詞 あ 自動詞っていうことになるんですね
自動詞ですかね intransitive
は そうすると だからヴィハンニャティっていうのはハンは殺すって意味なんですけど
ヴィハンニャティは自動詞ですから
破壊になる 破滅になるという風にしか訳できないんですね
まあ意味はそれぐらいすごく簡単な言葉で
まあだからお釈迦様の教えの特色がありまして
なんかすごい簡単に聞こえる
単純に聞こえるというところはね
それはまあお釈迦様の言葉のすごい大事な特色なんです
で たまにどうしようもない時はもうちょっと言うところもありますけど
そうなるともうなかなか人間の頭では理解できないほどものすごい難しくなってしまうし
逆にまあお釈迦様はたくさん語っているところはすごく簡単で
すぐ ああ なるほど そういうことですかと
すぐ理解できるような言葉で真理を語るんですよ
だから これほど分かりやすく語っているところと
また論理的にね 語っている文章っていうのは
だいたい世界ではないんです
で もう一度意味を考えてみると
まあ悪人はね いわゆる悪いことをする人が
まあ今も悩んで これからも悩んで
それから自分の悪行をね
まあそれからもう悩んで悩んで
もう破滅になる なぜそうなるかというと
やっぱり自分のこの悪行を見ると
悩むことしかなくなっちゃう
できなくなっちゃうんですね
それからこうしなさい
ああしなさいとかね 余計なおせっかいはしないんですね
お釈迦様は ただ事実を語っておく
で 余計なおせっかいはない
だから人間の理性に語るという立場をとってますから
だから理性ある人が 自分がどうするべきかということを自分で決めてほしいんです
で 理性ない人が このもうもう何て言いますかね
こうしなさいと言うまではやらないんですね
起きなさいと言うまでは起きないし
歩けと言うまでは歩けないし
食えと言うまでは食べないしっていう
そういう人にはやっぱり何か真理わかるか
何か発見できるかっていうのはありえないんですよ
ただ操り人形みたいだからね
だからそれで人生素晴らしいと言っちゃうとね
あまり意味がないんですよ
だからやめなさい やりなさいとかね
それが仏教はあえて避けるんです
で それでだからといって人は放っておくわけじゃなくて
情報を与えてあげる まあこういうこと
こういうこと こういうことですと
それでストップするんです
それで聞いた人が では私は何をするべきかということは
自分の理性を使って判断して行動すればいいんです
自分の理性を使って判断して行動する場合は
また何か何か問題が起きたら
それはこういうことですとまた教えてあげる
だから仏法 ブッダの説法と呼ぶんですけど
説法っていうのは真理を語る
おせっかいっていうわけじゃないんです
説教ではないんです 説法なんです
だから仏教も一つの宗教に入って入れてるんだからね
歴史的にはね だからといって宗教の特色はもうそういう残念なことにないんですね
宗教っていうのはもうわけもわからなく
ああしなさいこうしなさいと
人間にもう随分いろいろ命令するだけで
そこで人間もまあだらしないんだからね
これすごい好きなんですね
何か命令されると まあそのままやると
だから自分で判断して行動させるっていうことは
大体まああまり好きじゃないんですね
だから人間には欠けているものっていうのは
この理性というものなんですよ
で それで人間としてはかなりまだまだ何といいますか
人間の資格は得てないんですね
理性がない場合は だから
この論理性やら理性とか
よく具体的でね 物事を見て考えて行動するっていうことは
やっぱり人間どうしてもやらなくちゃいけないことなんです
しかし 人間っていうのは
このどんどんどんどん社会が成長して変化していくたびに
あのまあ そのまんまま生きていきたがるんですね
いわゆるそのまんまっていうのは
犬猫みたいにね 餌もらったら食うと
鎖で縛っておけば そのまま黙って寝ていると
では散歩ですと言ったら喜んで一緒に散歩に行くと
それでいい子になったと
という生き方 特に現代社会っていうのはね
すごく複雑になっているんだから
まあみんないい子になりたがるんですね
いい子っていうのは まあ一応飼い飼ってる犬と私
全然生き方は変わらないんですね
決まってる 誰か誰かセットしているこのからくりの中
それに合わせる自分を
合わせて安心している
で 何を得られるかというと
まあ別に何も得られませんね
ただ食って年取って死ぬ
それで人生終わり 人間として人間らしく生きるということは
もう今の時代ではないんです
誰も人間らしく生きてるわけじゃない
ただまあ世の中いろんなものあるんだから
それに操られて振り回されて走り回って途中で死ぬという
だからまあ これは昔もね
人間っていうのはそういう生き方好きなんですね
好んでるんですよ 私を誰が飼ってくれと
私を誰が飼って餌をくれと
それで吾輩は満足やと
その気持ちはずっとあるんですね
だから世の中で現れる宗教っていうのはそれを狙ってるんです
だから他の商売よりは宗教のお客さんの数が多いんです
逃げないんです だからこのあまりにも束縛されちゃって
例えばカトリック教なんかではね
まあ教会の人々に気に入らなかったら簡単に落とすんですよ
あなたの遺体は教会ではもう何て言いますか
埋葬しませんと それ言われると
追っちゃうと何でもやる
それぐらい怯えちゃうんですね
[背景音楽]大きなお世話ですよというぐらい自信はないんです
死んだら何したっても関係ないんだと
遺体は埋葬しようか火葬しようかね
その連中はなんかやるでしょうと
そんなもの そんな脅しは効かんぞというぐらいはできませんね
だからこの成長してない
精神的にできてない人間っていうのは
いつでもこの まあ飼ってほしいんですね
自分を 誰かに だからこの世界の宗教のこのシステムというのをね
だいたい知識的に分析してみると
その飼って欲しがってる人々を飼ってやる
それだけ 私のところに来いと
君にはすべて与えるぞと
というだけで 何一つも与えたことはないんです
人間は神がくれて幸せになったものは一つもないんです
人間全部自分の手で足で頑張って汗流して得たものばっかりなんですけど
そこでそちら読んでいたって雨が降ってるんではないかと
ちゃんと太陽が昇ったり沈んだりしてるんではないかと
そんな恵みはあるかと
他は ああそうですかと思って手をそのままでいてみてください
食えるかと 何もしないで
口には飛んでこないよ
食べ物は だから人間自分で努力しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは否定するんだから
堂々と お釈迦様はありのままに言う
世の中を見るとね 努力しないと動物さえも生きていられませんと
飼ってくれていてもね
買って餌くれる人はいないと
犬にしたっても犬猫ぐらいでしょう
まあ一応もう動物の中でも飼ってもらいたくいるのはね
しかし仕事をしないと捨てられますからね
まあそれはまあ宗教の特色で
お釈迦様はすごい革命的に
そういうものにはものすごいこの
違うことを真理は違うと
ありのままに見なさいと
約束はダメだと 信じる信じることできんと
永遠の命なんか約束したってもね
でしたら この今ここで体験しなくちゃいけないんだと
言ってることは本当かないか
自分が幸福になるかならないかっていうことは
今すぐ試してみなきゃダメよと
というふうな思考で修行して真理を発見して語ってます
だからこの本当のことをあることを言うんだからわかりやすいんです
しかし 買ってほしい人間はわかりませんと堂々と言うんです
そこで天国に神様が永遠にいるんだと言ったら
ああそうですか よくわかりましたというんですよ
神様のところで懺悔すれば
あなたの罪は全部なくなりますと
なんてありがたい話ですかと言うんです
よくわかるんですね みんな
で 今言ったのは このお釈迦様の言い方がすごいこの真理だけ語って置いておくところなんですね
それだからこのそこからも仏教の立場が違う
我々は本来はこの買われてほしいという気持ちでいるんですけど
これやめなさいと 目を開けて具体的に世の中を見なさいよっていうのは仏教の立場で
それで目を開けて世の中を見なさいと言ったってもわからないんだからね
見たことがないんだから
では目を開けて世の中を見るとこういうことがあるんだそうと
それで一つ ここは今のこの悩むことについてね
だから誰が悩むかというと
悪いことをする人が悩むんだと
それで自分を観察すればするほど
もう悩んで悩んで悩んで悩んで
もうもう破壊になってしまうんだと
それからこの今日も悩むんだから
もうやっぱり明日になっても悩むんだから
時間関係で考えちゃうと
この人もとことんとことん悩むことになるんですね
だからイダっていうのはここという訳でもよろしいし
この世でという意味でもよろしいし
ペッチャっていうのはこれからという訳でもよろしいし
もう死後という意味でもよろしいんです
あの世でとも どちらでもよろしいんです
で そこであの方の質問に
もうちょうど入りやすいとは思います
しかし 私たちは見ている世界ではそうとも限らないではないかと
社会を見るとね  やっぱり悪いことをする人々は凶暴で
あのうまくいっているようには見えます
でもそれがこの私たちの主観であって
本当に悪いことをしている人に聞いてみたらどうですか
だから一見我々には幸せそうに
凶暴で力強いように見えるんだけど
本人たちは結局私たちよりもひどい不幸で生きているんですよ
だからこの何でしょうかね
だから悩むって何なのか
幸せって何なのかっていうところの定義に戻さなくちゃいけないんですよ
私たち 騙されてるんですよ
まあ例えばまあまあ万ぐらいの給料で
まあ家賃も払って ローンも払って
教育費も払っちゃうと
まあ食べるものは少々遠慮しないとということになって
まあなんとか生きている
そういう人々は 1週間
1週間で あるいは 1時間
2時間仕事をして 万もらっている人のことは羨ましくて
なんて幸せですかとか思っちゃう
あれは錯覚なんですよ
本当にそういう人々が幸せですか？と
そこで 1週間で万儲かる人々から
税金はだいたい 80%以上取っちゃうでしょ
で 残らないんですね 結局は
残らないところで何するんですかというと
欲を出しちゃっていろいろからくりをする
それでやがてバレる それで全部なくなっちゃう
でも万円でなんとか奥さんに怒られながら
あれ人々そんなことには会わないでしょ
一応 だから私たちのちょっとした弱みがあって
他人のことを見て あの人は羨ましい
あの人は才能があってなんと羨ましい
あの人にはお金がいっぱいあってなんて羨ましいとかね
それが我々のすごい弱みなんですよ
他人を見るなかれと 自分の足元を見なさいとお釈迦様言うんですよ
他人のこと見てよかったのではないかと
自分も喜びはそれで十分です
自分の友達の収入は月々万円やと
一緒に勉強して一緒に遊んで生活していたのに
自分がではなくてだと 0
一つないと それで別にどうってことないんですよ
君はもうちゃんと収入あって
の収入あっていいんじゃないかと
よかったんじゃないかと
しっかり頑張れと その人を
もうそういう風に応援してあげて
自分は自分の足元をちゃんと見て生活すれば
それが幸せではないかなというのは仏教的な見方なんですね
だから他人を見ちゃうと頭が混乱して私たちを悪に陥れる
だから あの質問にあったのは
どなたでも考える一般論なんです
皆様の経験で見ると やっぱり悪い奴らうまくいってるんではないかということはね
これ私の個人的な経験から見ても同じ感情ですよ
感想ですよ やっぱり私の周り見てもからくりやってる人
悪いことをやってる人は結構うまくいってるんです
だから別に私の周りは違うというわけじゃないんです
だから我々は一般的に考えちゃうと
はぁ あんな悪いことまでして
私の世界から一つ例出しますけど
ある人は頭が悪くて勉強できなくて
研究もできなくて 全然もうダメですね
それで私はその人に資料
データ友達だからね こういうものを見てみなさいと
あなたに必要なデータ全部ありますよ
見たってもわからない
それは組み合わせできない
私は一人で考えて この人はなんで大学に入って研究生するんですかと
そこでなんとか仕事をすればいいんじゃないかと
って言ってもとにかくもうすごいあれで
それで私はもう書いてあげたんです
しょうがない で 私はもうあんた書きなさい
私は言うだけやと言って
もう全部まあ言って言って言って言って言って
自分ではアプローチちゃうとものすごい労働だからね
やりたくないんだと 自分ではそれぐらいのことでもやってくださいって全部資料を合わせて
で 書いたらもう抜群にもう大学は OK と
それでいいやと 向こうは知らない
これ誰がやったもんかと
私に言うんですね あなたもああいう風に研究したらどうですかねと
もう蹴ったくなるんですよ
教授まで このアホやと
自分の弟子だからね 能力ぐらいは理解しなさいと言いたいんだけど
私はそうですねと それしか言えないんだからね
それでは終わらなかったんです
私は研究の世界から追い出そうと何もこともできないんだと
そこまで頑張る で 今もうまくいってますけどね
うまくいってるんだけど
何も仕事できなくて 学位だけ名前だけ取って
世間には迷惑やと思いますけどね
ああいう人々からもう勉強する連中はどうなるかと
私は知ったことないんだからね
私はもうやめたんだからね
私はやめたのはそういう周りがいたんだから
やっぱり私はやめてみると
悪人と一緒にいるよりはね
一人でいた方がもうなんとなくではないかと
まあだから自分の個人的な周りを見ても
悪い奴らばっかしうまくいって
真面目に仕事をする場合はもう蹴っ飛ばされると
実際にあるんですけど
やっぱりそういう思考は騙されてる思考なんですね
それで私はまあ知ってる人々だから
まあたまに会うことあったら
こういう人たちの生き方何なのかと見るとね
全く落ち着きがなくて 24
時間も神経質で もう自分のもう強引に得た立場を守らなくちゃいけないし
それで私はもうニコニコと笑って
誰とも遊んでふざけて
それは全然できません
たまにあっても のこのこと私からまたいろんなことを頼むんですよ
ああいうことまであって
こういうところでこういう国際シンポジウムがあって行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
なんとか書いてくれませんか？とかね
私はもうその世界とは関係ない
私はただ説法してるボスですよと
だからあんた方とはもう全然会いませんよと
で 断ったりします どれも断らない場合は
まあなんとか書いてあげますけど
それでも私は 2ページ書いちゃう
その人にももう 1年  2年経ってもそれぐらいのことは書けないんです
だから私が考えているのは
では誰が幸せで安心して生きてるかと
私の方が幸せで安心して生きてるんです
私の足を引っ張ったって引っ張るところないんだから
私は地面にいるんだから
その人は雲の上にいるんだからね
ちょっと滑っちゃうともう粉々になるんだから
だから自分の国ではことわざがあるんですよ
で 時々この家に人が来ると
あの椅子とかいうところでどうぞかけてくださいと言うんですよ
時々この謙虚な人々は
いえ 床はたわれませんよと
床に座るんです この床はたわれませんということは
自分が謙虚でいると それ以上何て言いますか
落ちるということはないんだよ
だから自分の何て言いますか
身分より上のところには座ってはいけないんだと
できれば椅子に座るべき人でも
床に座っていた方がもっといいんだと
安定しているんだと ということわざなんですけどね
まあことわざはまあ床に座ったら落とせませんと
という短いことわざなんです
そういうことだから やっぱり世の中では人間が精神的な安らぎを味わっているかというと
悪いことをする人々っていうのは
その悪いことを隠すために神経を絞らないとね
大変ですよ そこでもう一つ言いたいことは
このだいたいこの掃除機ものを馬鹿見るというね
日本の言葉もありますよ
これは掃除機ものを馬鹿見るんじゃなくて
掃除機だけじゃなくてバカなんですよ
バカだからバカを見るんであって
だからこの理性使っちゃうと
理性で物事を考えたら
自分の命 自分の幸福 どうすれば安定になるかっていうぐらいは自分で考えろと
ただ掃除機だけでね やっぱりそれがバカなんですよ
掃除機だから馬鹿みたいじゃないんです
例えば自分一緒に仕事をするところで
もう汚い人がいるんだと
その人は色々からくりしちゃうんだと
しちゃうと自分が掃除機だから黙っている
それで捕まる時は自分と一緒に捕まって
ところでやっぱり自分が掃除機だから馬鹿見たんではなくて
バカだから馬鹿見ちゃったことになるんですよ
自分の身ぐらい守っておかないと
この世の中で身を守ることっていうのはないと生きていられないんだからね
だからこの理性がある人は
まあちゃんと身を守られます
まあだからまあそこら辺のちょっとね
これは人間 弱みですからね
あまり大胆なことはできないし
行動活発的な行動もできなくて
それで掃除機かぶっちゃうんですよ
ただ単に掃除機かぶっただけでもいいわけじゃない
掃除機かぶる前に理性を育ててほしい
理性育てちゃうと もう掃除機なんですよ
善悪を知っていて もうこれやったらこうなるんだよと
だからやりませんと 自分の友達がやるんだったら
ではあんたは自分でやってくださいと
私はあなたのことを密告することもしないし
私に関係ないし せいぜい頑張ってください
でも私だけは引っ込むなよと
間違うなよと 巻き込んだらただじゃ済みませんよと
しかし 私は誰にも密告もしない
友達だから あんたのことはね
それは私の責任を負うしかないと
だから頑張ってくださいと
放っておけばいいんです
その人は自分の行為で自分が破滅するになるんであって
まあそういうことだから
世の中では人間はね まあもう本当に掃除機で生きてみようとする人々いるんですけど
やっぱり理性にかけているんですね
これで大変なことになっちゃうんですね
だから たとえ悪人たちが勝ってる
勝ってるように見えても
我々は理性を保って自分を守るということでやっちゃうと
まあそう悪くはならないんですね
で 例えば世界の経済活動は全部今アメリカの裏の計画がありまして
この全てアメリカ合衆国が有利になるように動かさなくちゃいけないということで
ユーロは壊すはもうどんな組織も壊して壊して
いろいろまあやってますけど
ですから 確かに世界の経済は支配してね
自分やりたい放題をやっているということは
もうものすごい幸せで平安でいられるはずでしょ
しかし 毎日怯えていますよ
毎日怯えています 皆様も正直なこと言ってみて
皆様安心して旅に出るのは日本の国内旅行
あるいはアメリカ旅行
世界一の国だから アメリカに行った方はもっと胸を張って
もっと羽を伸ばして生きるはずでしょうに
でも怯えていくでしょうに
誰にやるのかわからないんだから
ということは もう１週間２週間の旅行で怯えるんで
そこで永住している人々はどうですかね
だから これが何かちょっと理屈はね
人間がただ あの 何て言いますか
この思考は逆さまで不幸に幸福という幸福に不幸という
穏やかで平和で心配することなくいることはつまらないと
戦って攻撃して歯を噛んで
憎しみで苦しみで もうもうとことんやってる
頑張ってるなとかね 頑張ってるんじゃなく
自分の肉自分で食ってるだけなんですね
生で だから私たちはこのちょっとこの錯覚がありまして
このあべこべ思考を持ってますね
その世界は誰でもね あべこべ思考を持ってるんだから
あの そういう風に悪い人々は本当に幸せではないかなという風に我々は錯覚を起こす
そこで幸せの定義を考えた方がいいんです
幸せっていうのは お金があっただから幸せということは言えるかと
課長 社長になっただから幸せと言えるかと
幸せは課長でも社長でという立場にあるわけじゃないし
総理大臣になっただから幸せとか
そういうところにあるわけないんだからね
総理大臣でいたっても
後で裁判でいろいろ調べることはあり得るでしょうし
だからそういうところじゃないんですよ
やっぱり心の安らぎなんですよ
充実感ですね だから本当に私は悪いことをしてない
ないなと 今まで生きていて
後ろめたいと思うことをやったことはないと言うと
ものすごい精神的な安心感を味わうんです
人に隠すものはないんだと
それがそうそう接する幸せなんですよ
隠すものあればあるほど大変な苦しんでいるんです
だから悪いことをする人にとってはあるのは隠すものばっかしで
結局はありすぎて隠しきれなくなっちゃうんですね
一つ二つ生まれると 全部鎖みたいな感じで次から次へと出ていく
例えば逮捕されたっていても
そこら辺にいる普通の人なんか警察に捕まって逮捕したっててもね
そんなに大差さないんですよ
家にいると あるいはまあそちらに
刑務所でどこかに留置場とかなんとか入れちゃうでしょ
まあそちらで 1週間いるとか
まあそんな大差さないんですよ
しかし すごい偉い人の場合はどうですかね
究極の贅沢にいる人々はね
逮捕されちゃうと そこら辺で何か変なことをして
小細泥棒やって あるいは麻薬をやって何かして捕まった人と一緒にいなくちゃいかんだからね
それかなりやられます
だからやっぱり 心の安らぎは悪いことをしていないんだということが大変な心の安らぎ
幸せなんです まあ確かに今の質問に出た質問には
お釈迦様は別なところで答えてあるんです
悪いことをする人はバレるまでは威張ってますよと
でも自分の悪行為は この灰の中に隠れている罪の罪とは言えない
何でしたっけ？火の玉
この炭火ありますね 炭火っていうのはすぐ上
灰で隠せますけど でも消えません
そういう風にずっとごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃと自分を悩ませて
やがてしちゃうんだよと
で そういうこと答えがあります
まあそれからこの悪いことって何なのかというと
やっぱりなんで悩むのかというとね
やっぱり悪いことを考えて行動する時点でもう心が悩みをもうスタートしているんです
で 悪いことといえば やっぱりこの怒りとかね
憎しみとか 余計な欲とか
まあ例えば浮気しようかなと思った時点から悩んでるんじゃないんですかね
あっちこっち友達を作って
もうよく頑張ってるんだよと羨ましいと思ったっても
本人はね 浮気しようと思った瞬間からもうもう火の玉が現れてるんです
そういうことだから この心がもう一応汚れた原因
出てきて それで行動しようとする
その時点からもう自己破壊になります
必ずしもこれは自己破壊行為なんですね
真理としては なぜかというと
自分の心でこの悪の種が現れちゃったんですね
悪っていうのは必ず燃やしちゃうんですね
だから 他人にバレるかバレないかということは問題ではありません
仏教になってくると そこは考えるんです
誰かさんがね 悪いことをして
もう死ぬまでもう頑張ってよく生けてた
全然気にしない そういうことは
だから 他人にバレるかバレないかということは問題ではありません
本人にバレてるんだから
やってる本人に いわゆる自分の心は知ってるんだから
心にはそれは避けることはできません
だからべったし自分と同一になってるんです
罪が だから 燃えて不幸になることは避けられなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 仏教の人々はたまたま一時的に人が悪事を働かせて成功していることは全然羨ましいとも思わないんです
私に小さい頃母が言ったのは
悪いことをしてご飯食べるよりは飢えた方が立派だよと
よく覚えてるねと なぜかというと
もう私たちは昔の人間だから
村でそんな人の家の塀とか
そんなのほとんどないし
もうもう行きたいところな行っちゃうわ
遊びところどこでも遊ぶわ
もう誰の家にも平気で入っちゃうわ
もう何のことない 昔ですからね
世界はすごい自由でしたから
だからまあ遊んでいる途中で食べる時期になったら
もうそこら辺のどこの家でも食べちゃう
誰もそんなに気にしない
もうご飯の時期だったら
誰かそこら辺遊んでるんで呼ぶんですよ
君も遊ぶ時間じゃないとご飯食べる時間でしょうと
ご飯食べなさいと そういうことだから
やっぱりかなり母たちは心配する
子供たちはもう管理できません
どこに走ってるかわからないし
追っかけて行ったって意味がないし
だから外で悪いことしちゃうと困ると
一番ご飯というのは その家の叔母さんたちが勝手にくれるもんだから
食べちゃってもいいんだけど
で いろんな人の家で いろんなところで果物やいろいろ栽培作ってるでしょうね
それ見たら子供にはちょっと我慢できんだからね
すぐ手が行くんです で
小さい頃もそれ一つの遊びの一種でしたからね
藪に入っていろいろ食べるものを探しましょうとかね
そうするとすごい小さないろんな木の実やらいろんなものいっぱいありますよ
それで食べるもの 食べられるもの
食べられないものとか分けて
これは毒出そうとかね
そういう風に分けて食べたりして
それでも時々一つジャム作りものありますね
じゃあ何でしたっけ すごい色が激しい
小さな あ ブルーベリー
ブルーベリーっていうのは今栽培して別だけど
その種類がいろいろありますよ
そこで小さい頃自慢するんですね
藪に入って食べちゃうと
この口やら歯やらもうもう全くもうもうもう青い色で
自慢したく気持ちもあってね
見つけたぞとかね 結局家に行ったらかなりやられますけど
自慢する前にやられちゃいますけど
だからやっぱりこのもし人の家で育てている木なんかに手が行っちゃうと
これ困ると だからこういう人のものを勝手に取って食べたり
それだったらもうもうそれよりはもう死んだ方がいいやと
ということで それは仏教的な道徳で
このまあ悪いことをして食べるよりは飢え死になる方がすごい立派でかっこいいんだと
それが道徳的な仏教でいうことで
だから誰かが悪いことをして成功していたってもかっこいいとは思わないんですね
しかし その人がそれバレて不幸になったっても
よかったよかった 罰が当たったのではない
それも思ってはいけない
思わない それも それもすごい
切実なやり方 できれば助けてあげようとする
まあ一応まあ複雑な話は複雑になって申し訳ないんですけど
この 私たちはだいたいこの
充実感があって生きてきたい
我ながら頑張ってるんだぞと自分に言い聞かせたいんですよ
普通そうでしょ？何やってもうまくいかないんだぞとは言いたくない
考えたくもない 普通人間っていうのは
我ながらなかなかやってるんだよと
という気持ちが これが幸せなんですよ
ということはどういう働きかというと
私たちは常に自分が何をやったかということを見ているんです
自分が これがみんなやってます
きれいさっぱり全て忘れるということはできない
だから いつでも私が何やったかなと自分のことを観察する
そう観察するときは もう自分では一応答え決まってるんです
まあ我ながらなかなかやってるんではないかと
それが自分で言いたいんだけどできない場合はどうしますかね
だから悪いことをする人は悩むんですよ
例えば百万儲けたっても
私はかなり頭が鋭く商売上手だなというふうに人に言うかもしれませんだけど
一人で自慢できないんですね
でも私はこういうふうに相手を騙したんではないかと
あのお金にあんまり重さがないんですよ
あの なんとかなんとかの
まあ宗教まがいのことをやってね
すごい金ももう一年二年でね
もう何億単位で人々から金取って
もうすごいまあまあ死亡一つまた見ますけどね
それで神様になっちゃってね
まあかなり態度-- 短いんですね
やっぱり命は それでみんな私の一千万円騙し取ったと
ガン治しますよとかね
占いをしてこうしてやってくれる
これぐらい騙した これぐらい騙したとかね
みんなまとめて吹っ飛ばしたりするし
ではその人は私こそ神様だと威張っていられるかと
やっぱりずっと人を騙してるんだから
自己観察するとかなり惨めになるだろうと思いますよ
だからなんでそんな生き方をするのかと
普通にいればいいのに
[背景音楽]普通で幸せなのに
突然もうゼロを四つ三つ五つ入ってるぐらい金が欲しがってる
それで一番早いのはまあもう超能力売ることなんですね
日本では ハンドパワーで癌を治すと
それでみんな群がっちゃう
ハンドパワーだからお金かからんだからね
無料でやればいいんだけど
やっぱりもう五百万とか一千万とかはなっちゃうんですね
一千万あるんだったら
アメリカでも行ってちゃんとした治療しなさいと私が言いたいんですけど
遺伝子治療でもうあるし
だからね やっぱりこの単純に考えましょう
私たちだったらやっぱりいいことをしたんだぞとかね
うまくいったんだぞとかね
ふうに自分で自慢したいんですよ
他人に言うんじゃなくて
うまくいったと 人に言うとそれはすごいあれですけど
やっぱり人に言うもんじゃない
それは 自分のことを見ると
ああ 結構うまくやってるんではないかと
やっぱり自分で自慢することが必要なんです
自分一人で 誰にも言わないで
だからそういう人が幸せなんです
そういう人は他人に自慢はしません
満足しているんだからね
いえいえ なんのことない
ただたまたまとか そういう風に言うんですよ
あなたってすごいですね
あれ たまたま まあただただもううまくいっただけですよとかね
で 謙虚な言葉言いながら
本人は本当は喜んでいるんです
それが決して悪い生き方じゃないんです
もし他人に言いふらすならば
どこかで穴があるんですよ
だから他人に認めてくれ
褒めてくれという あると
もう不幸のどん底 ではなくて
すごい謙虚でね もう私だったらもうダメですねとか何とかとかね
と言いながら自分を控えながらもう言うんですけど
本当は本人が結構自信満々で
もう満足感でいる それが幸せ
私はこういうこともしました
こういうこともしました
ハガキぐらい大きな名刺まで作ったりとかね
出すともう最悪なんですよ
ある自分の国の人なんですけど
このもうインチキ嘘ばっかしで有名になっちゃって
で こちらに来て 当時で私は大使館と結構いろんなことで随分もう行ったり来たりして
今は関係ないんですけどね
で 大使館の人と何かあったらいつも私に聞いてアドバイスを受けたり
いろいろなことをやっていて
で なんかこういう なんかすごい人が来るんですけど
ちょっと心配やと なぜかというと
この政治家やらいろいろコネ持っていて
それは名前何ですか？と
ああそう 別に気にしなくていいんじゃないのと
それだけ言ったんですよ
そんなに気にすることないでしょと
でも聞いて すごくもうかなりもう胸を張って言うわ
言うわ 言うわ それでもう大使館の人が私にこのこういう名刺もらった
名刺見せたんですね 名刺の大きさ
普通の名刺と二倍もうちょっとあるんで
まあハガキぐらいで ハガキの名刺っていう言葉そこで作ったんで
私は ポストカードサイズのネームカード
で そこでいろいろいろいろいろいろ書いてあるんですけど
ちゃんと見ると全部怪しいと
すぐわかるんですけど
それでうまいことに何か国際関係でなんとかのもう政府ですごく偉い人がね
この管理の一番上の誰かが来るということになって
で またこの人はその人は私の何々さん知ってるんだっていう形で大使館で言って
もうあんたもちょっとそういう人いるんだっけ？ちょっと行って
あの 喋った方がいいんじゃないかなと言われて
大使館もちょっとあまりにも有名なすごい知識人でね
すごい人で で こちらからやっぱりそれなりの人を出したいんですね
私は暇がないんですけどって言って
もうそうためらったんですけど
とにかく行ったんです
行けばこの人も一緒に来たんで
一緒に来て いつでも私を随分した
あんたなんかもう小人扱いですね
あなたにそんな態度をとる権利はないなって気持ちはあるんですよ
でもまあいいやと 別にその人に連れて行くような感じで
お世話係の感じで行ったんです
言ってもあの見てこの人はちょっと神経質なのでちょっと喋らないんです
一応 ただ 私は何のことなく
その人も友達みたいな感じで
どうこういうことでいろいろ喋ったんです
ちょっと喋っただけで怯えたんです
このハガキの名刺持ってる人は
怯えてこっちこっちから汗が出て
だからね 威張るなよと
初めから 初めから人の能力を知っておいて研究で行った方がそんな恥かかないでしょって
それ気持ちなんですよ
で それからもう私に対しては随分気を付ける
で まあわかりやすく言えば
この人はものすごい頭いい学者
超学者という風に言ってるんですけど
まあだいたいスリランカでも上の上のランクになってくると
みんな英語で喋るんですよ
国の言葉でもなくて 英語にまたいろいろランクがあるし
グッドモーニングとかね
サンキューぐらいは誰でもできますけど
もう獅子身になってくると
英語の使い方はまた変えてすごい違う
ただ それだけのことです
私は普通に挨拶して もうちょっと世間話をちょっとしただけで
一言もわからないんですね
何を喋っているかという
それであのものすごい風船がすんと切れてしまったんですね
そういうふうな感じで
やっぱり人がもう名刺は3倍に大きくして
もうあれやこれやとかやっちゃうと
やっぱり穴があるんですよ
いわゆるそれは行ったのは別に何かあるならば書かなくちゃいけないしね
自分の自分がこういうものを知るためには
別に不相でいいんで それでも
やっぱり自分がこういうものだ
こういう人だ こんなことやってるんだ
もうこんな偉い人やと言いふらすと
もう必ずしもその人は自分では満足していないということになるんです
逆に私は別にもうもうもうたまたまもう何のこともできんかったこと研究にいる人はもうやっぱり結局は自分が自分なりに頑張っているんだと
という満足感があります
それで私たちが自分の能力で頑張っていると
それも不正を働かさないで能力を生かしていると最高に喜べるんですよ
自分で自慢できます 一人で
誰もいないところで だから一人で誰もいないところで自分
自分自己持賛っていうんですか
自分で自分を持賛できれば
その人は本当に幸福なんです
誰も聞いてないんだからインチキできんでしょ
だから本物なんです そこでからくりをやって人を騙してうまくいっても
世間では褒めてくれるんだけど
本人が一人になるとあの幸福が消えてしまう
やっぱり悩むことになる
そういうわけで これが法則なんです
悪いことをして悩まずにはいられないんです
そこは次から次へと悪循環でまたどんどん広げていきます
先生  はい  貪瞋痴に基づづくことは全部悪なんです
うん  自分では気づかずに悪をしていることも結構ある
うん だからなかなか自慢できんでしょ
一人では [笑い]そういうわけなんです
悪い結果になったり 自慢できない状態になってたら
何か悪を自分がしてたんだと
になりますね はい  十五番のところは自分と他人を比べるとちょっと色々分かりづらいかもしれないんですけど
自分自身について自分がいいことをしている時と悪いことしている時と比べれば明らかにこのことは
うん そうですね だからこれは他人と比べる芸じゃないんです
どうせ仏教はそれを認めませんしね
他人と比べるのは 他人は他人で自分は自分だからね
だから私はこの自分で自慢できるかないかというポイントを持ってきたのはそういうわけなんです
だから本当に幸せかないかということは
自分一人で自分のことは自慢できるかと
それで自慢できるようにしなくちゃいけない
だから人に言ってはいけませんと
人に言う気持ちあるんだったら
あんたかなり穴 あなたの人格には結構穴が開いてる
大きい穴があるんだよということなんですね
だから自分で楽しく 我ながらよくやってるんだよという気持ちなんですね
それを自分一人だけになってくると
明確にこの芸は生きてるんです
いいことをしちゃうと
なんだかすごい楽しい
隠したい気持ちもない
で 人があんたすごくいいことをしたんでは
ないないなんたことないと
さらにそれはちょっともう謙虚で答えたりもする
そうですよとは言わない
私はもうやるんだったらいいことしかやりませんよとか
そんなことは全然言わないしね
そんなこと言っちゃうと
それだけでその人はダメっていうことはわかる
先生 これは十八の方に続いてくる
もう全部大体通じますよ
全部 十八までも同じことを続けてましたから
いっぺんに全部まとめて意味を言ったってもいいんです
善と悪っていうのは感覚ということですか
感覚でもないんで そういうのは事実ですから
これ私個人の気持ちとは全然関係ないんですよ
だから心っていうのは私の個人的なものというわけじゃなくて
一つの宇宙的なものなんですよ
だから自分の好き勝手ではもういかないんですよ
だから感覚的っていうのは
私においしいとかなんとかことでしょう
だから自分の感覚では決められません
例えばこの あの世界一
もう世界全ての軍隊をまとめたっても
アメリカの軍隊には勝てないんだよと
すごい能力ある すごい訓練を受けてますよと
だから平気で勝てるぞと思って
いろいろ殺したりする場合でも
まあ感覚的な自慢でしょ
見てみろと 我々には勝てるわけがないぞというね
しかし それでもうまくいかない
感覚的には 悪いことは悪いんです
時々いますよ 殺したりすることがすごい楽しいと思う人々は
魚を釣ったりとかね 狩りに行ったりとかね
だから表面的な感覚では遊んでるんですよ
でもやってることは殺生ですよ
後でかなり悩むことになります
ある感覚のうちで悪いものといいものがあるっていう
感覚はそんなに当てになりません
悪いものは客観的にあるんです
これが悪いと で いいものも客観的な真理な普遍的な真理なんです
私たちの問題は それをわからないってことなんですね
それをお釈迦様はどんどんどんどん真理としてダラダラダラダラと言ってるんです
これが普遍的な真理だよと
欲 貪瞋痴だと激しい感覚があるけど
それ激しいものではなくて
落ち着いた状態になるっていう
そのものに目指すものだったら
それは善っていう  違う
欲は悪といったら欲は激しくあろうか小さかろうが悪いんですよ
ただ 激しい欲の結果は激しく悪い
弱い欲の結果は その分結果も弱いだけのこと
貪瞋痴が悪いと言ったら
これは悪い 明らかに悪い
貪瞋痴がもう起きない
ない状態が  そこをね 反対のエネルギーを作らなくちゃいけない
それは今わからない 貪瞋痴しかないんだから
ですから いろいろお釈迦様は実践方法も教えている
例えば欲があるんだから
もらう時楽しいでしょ
儲かる時は楽しい それは欲があるんだから
それ感覚なんですよ でもそれ悪いことだから
いくらもらってももらってももうキリがない
もっと欲しいと思う で
不満が生まれてくる 塩水飲んでるような感じになっちゃうんですね
それで欲しい欲しい欲しいということでいっちゃうと
やがてもう全部もうダメになっちゃって
自己破壊のところに行ってしまう
怒りも同じで もう怒った瞬間では気分がいいんですよ
怒って相手に怒鳴った時はもうせいせいしますよ
それで次から次へ でもそれで終わらないんだからね
で 不幸がどんどんどんどん大きくなっていきます
だから我々知ってるのは欲の世界だけ
お釈迦様はあんたもらうだけじゃなくてね
人にあげることをやってみなさいと
人を助けることを考えてみなさいと
その時も全く質が違う喜びが生まれてくるんですよ
喜そういう時もあれば
そのいろいろいいことを慈悲のつもりでしてても
すごい気持ちいい時もあれば
それが欲になったりする
そういうところあります
まあそこら辺はまあすごくまあ別な時でも喋ろうかなと思ってます
すごい心のそういう問題もあります
完璧にならんない間はね
すごいごちゃになりますけどね
一応その前に先に簡単単純で
まあ自分でおいしいご飯を買って食べるだけではなくて
誰かに例えばホームレスな人にでもね
何かちょっと豪華な弁当でも買って
これどうぞ召し上がってくださいとかね
ちょっとあげてみたりすると
なんか不可思議な満足感を得られますよ
それが貪りと反対の欲と反対の喜びなんですよ
そうしちゃうと なんとなく一人でなんか自慢するんですね
そこで人にあんたバカじゃないか
あんなことやと言われたっても
自分ではそう思わないんですね
普通はあんた本当にバカなことやってますよってすぐバイト傷ついちゃうんですよ
でも いいことをしたところで
みんなにからかわれたっても
それまた全然平気で それまた喜んでいる
だから貪瞋痴は明らかに悪で
その反対の不貪不瞋不痴というね
貪りがない状態 怒りがない状態
無知がない状態が なんかものすごい質が違うんですけど
すごく増える喜びがそちらにあるんですよ
例えば千円の弁当食べる
美味しいんですよ 楽しいんです
その楽しみはそれで終わっちゃうんです
お金がないんだったら
毎日は食べられないないそうと思っちゃうと結局悲しいんですよ
あるいはすごいお金がある人だったら
もうまあこんな弁当って毎日食べたくないともっと美味しいものを食べたいとと思ったりするんだから
そんな大した幸福じゃないんですよ
しかし 自分がそんなに自由なお金もないのに
千円の弁当買って誰かにあげたとしますね
それは楽しみが消えませんね
面白いことに だから良い方はそれぐらい力があるんです
それが思い出してもまだ生きてますよ
あの千円は だからあげたならば
この思い出すたびに その千円は生きていて
自分に喜びを与える 自分で食べたならば一回で終わると
消えちゃった だから仏教の計算はお金ではしないんです
心で計算するんです 心の満足感で
充実感で計算するんですよ
だから千円で弁当食べると明らかに充実感
満足感は得られますけど
ほんの瞬間で消えると
そこであげるということをしちゃうと
あの千円は全然消えません
思い出すとまた生きている
また喜びを与えてくれる
また元気を与えてくれる
時々それぐらいのことで自慢するんじゃない
もっといいことをしなくちゃという風にもなるし
活発的にもなるし それで人をいっぱい助けるんだったら
やっぱり自分も頑張って仕事しなきゃダメやということで
仕事にも手が入っちゃう
目が入っちゃう しかし
欲がないその場合は 自分にお金があったらいっぱい良いことするんだからっていうことだから
そうすると仕事うまくいく
欲でやっちゃうとそれほど成功はしない
怯えがあるんだからね
そういう風なこの法則なんです
だから個人の好みで感情では考えるものじゃなくて
全て普遍的な法則になるんです
[背景音楽]